so what is this thing called nac
n acetyl l cysteine
what is that that doesn't explain
anything well that's a stable form of
cysteine which still doesn't explain
anything
cystine is a non-essential amino acid
basically it's a stabilizer
for the formation of protein structures
in your body
which still doesn't give you a lot of
information so i'm just going to go into
the benefits of what this is and how it
can help you
first of all it's something that can
increase one of the
most powerful antioxidants in your body
called glutathione
which means it can help counter
things like alcohol toxicity the toxic
effects from certain medications that
treat
adhd it can help reduce acne
especially the scars from acne it can
definitely help reduce addictions
like all addictions cocaine alcohol
nicotine food addictions because nac
helps normalize
neurotransmitters like glutamine
and dopamine which are both involved in
addictions it can help copd which is
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
because with this condition there's a
lot of oxidation going on
and inflammation nac helps reduce
mucus so it's good in pneumonia lung
issues
asthma bronchitis number seven it can
help reduce
ocd symptoms obsessive compulsive
disorder
symptoms number eight it can help reduce
depression
because it affects the neurotransmitters
as well as anxiety
number nine relieves autism why
because it affects the neurotransmitters
of the brain number ten it can help
certain disorders like bipolar
and even schizophrenia why because it
affects the neurotransmitters
and number 11 i did an entire video on
this it can help limit
tylenol induced liver damage
why because it's a very powerful
antioxidant
all right there you go i hope that
helped you
in understanding what nac really is
hey before you go real quick i have a
course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system
it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today